um so today i'm going to be talking
about um some recent work that we've
been doing at deepmind i'm developing uh
this line of architectures that we're uh
we're calling perceivers um and i'll be
motivate motivating this and in terms of
a goal that we have which is to develop
a general purpose architectures
um and so just right off the bat um
i want to motivate why we care about
general purpose architectures um and so
the first the first uh
both of the reasons are fairly pragmatic
but basically the idea is if we're
thinking about all of the data that we
could possibly imagine collecting in the
world um a lot of it um
is basically involves what we think of
as sort of traditional sense modalities
whether
these things range from touch and
proprioception to echolocation to uh the
kind of perception you need to to ingest
texts uh how however you want to format
that to things uh just to more exotic
things like event based cameras
um whisker touching touching with
whisker sensors things like smell and
depth um and all the way up to um the
kinds of sense modalities that we really
um think about when we're thinking about
scientific perception
um and so basically um as if we think
about the full set of data and what it
would take to actually model each of
these different modalities
it basically looks
effectively intractable to try to
engineer inductive biases that will work
for every single one of these so we
don't want to engineer them one by one
this is an approach that's worked and in
some ways it's maybe a reasonable
description of of how we think about
developing new architectures for
different uh different problems but it's
just not going to scale we we can't
afford as a community to design to hand
design inductive biases that will work
for each and every one of these and so
rather than doing that we want to sort
of build architectures that at least at
first pass will allow us to handle
everything
there's another practical argument for
why we should work on general purpose
architectures and that's because it will
allow us to build simpler more unified
systems um
so if you look at how in particular
complex multimodal data streams are are
typically um approached in uh in the
sort of the the sensory uh computer
vision or pattern recognition
literatures effectively the typical way
this is done is by using inductive
biases that we know hold for the
individual modalities and then engineer
ways to of combining those different
subsystems and so this could this can
mean building
specific specific heads specific input
modules for each of these things and
then trying out the various different
ways of combining them
and so this can work but it in this it
gives us systems that in principle
really will only work on one or a small
number of domains and it gives us
systems that are very hard to maintain
tend to be fragile uh tend to depend on
specific processing assumptions about
the input modalities
so rather than do that we sort of want
to move in the direction of having
unified black box architectures that
kind of just work
and the idea here is that if we can get
to that point we can abstract the
architecture construction process and
really focus on other more high-level
problems so this is sort of the the
motivation for this line of work
and the way that we're gonna that we're
gonna be doing this is of course by
working uh
on the most general purpose architecture
that we have so far which is basically a
transformer and you'll all be very
familiar with the basic building blocks
of a transformer
but just at a very high level we can
think about what they do right which is
they use a general purpose inductive
bias
so they're non-local which means they're
not making domain-specific assumptions
about which point should be compared to
each other rather they're they tend to
be global in terms of the attentional
focus that they have
they use position
as a feature rather than a hard
constraint of the architecture and this
is in contrast to um to sort of mlp
based architectures or or confnets in
the way that they typically work which
which use position as an architectural
component to constrain how compu calc
compute is happening
um and then of course they're they're
finally there's extensive there's
extensive weight sharing um in the way
that there's where that that they're
designed and because they focus on map
models they tend to be tpu and gpu
friendly so these are all very nice
things about the way transformers work
of course on the other hand they have
very poor compute memory scaling um and
there are two components to this so
attention itself scales quadratically so
there's this um
there's this big o of m squared l
um
uh complexity at the heart of
transformers and um i i like writing it
this way because it really emphasizes
that this is a property of um that
basically as you make your models bigger
either at the input size or as you make
them deeper you're just this problem is
just going to get worse
um
and because you have this uh this this
scaling and depth as well there's
another sort of practical thing that
happens here because we're um the the
the amount of compute that we're doing
is proportional to the input size so
there's no bottleneck in the way that
standard standard transformers work um
even the the linear scaling becomes a
problem um and so in practice um for for
very very large um transformers this can
often be the bottleneck that really
matters but they're both at play here
and so we really want to sort of tamp
down both of these um and so the the
sort of the perspective here is that to
have really general purpose
architectures we can't have ones that
are just sort of in principle general we
have ones that we have to have ones that
you can actually use um on the scales
and the kinds of data that we care about
um and so just to um
this will all be old hat for all of you
but just so the way that standard qkv
attention works is basically like this
so it's it's all about matrix
multiplication so we have some input we
compute the um the query keys and values
by having a 1d convolution a one by one
convolution that we run over the input
we then compute the attention uh the
attention scores this is a matrix
multiply that has the following
these sorts of shapes we then use the
output here to compute
the weights um to to compute the actual
output of the attention module itself
and then finally we want run this
through an additional mlp which is
applied convolutionally to get the
outputs
so this is this is the starting point of
what we're working on here
and let me just briefly um just
reiterate why we would want the sort of
advantages that we have with these sort
of standard transformers so non-locality
is one of the two sort of inductive bias
principles that we have here it's useful
i think to contrast this to way that to
the effective locality that you get in
confidence and what this actually means
so if we look at basically
as a function of depth which inputs can
see which other ones which means like
how how easily it is to express a
function of two input points um let's
say we we look at these this yellow and
purple point here at the input now
i've set them sort of as far apart as
possible but um we might ask what um how
deep would the effective computation
have to be before you actually process
these two and if you look at a three by
three convolution
you're talking um
you're having to look basically until
the very end of the of the network until
you're processing processing these
things together
and what this means is that um the
functions that that you can express that
actually look at both of these points
into being quite shallow because they
have to be built on top of this very
very deep stack that just gives you the
locality um and so in point of fact um
if you look at
for example the way resnets work so you
have an initial block which has a 7x7
convolution and then afterwards it's
three by three columns all the way up
you need 28 3x3 cons with that standard
processing stack before all of the 224
by 224 pixels in an image are looking at
each other
and what this means is that in a
resonant 50 um the points on the very
edge of the pixels actually never see
each other and this is um this is
it's a little bit i found this a little
bit counter-intuitive but it suggests
that we really are constraining quite a
lot the functions that are easy to
express with these models and so there
are some functions of images you just
can't you can't capture with a resonant
50.
on the other hand if you look at an
architecture that has global attention
over the full um over the full input so
a transformer if you could scale it that
way um or in a perceiver as we're going
to be talking about um all of the pixels
can interact so the model can basically
capture these things and express these
functions much more easily than can be
expressed in things that put locality
first
um we also um the other sort of
interesting property of these sorts of
architectures is that position is
featurized um and this basically means
that we're no longer sort of encoding
the architectural location of something
to to figure out um where it's located
with with respect to the other ones and
um this allows the network to basically
use um any uh any positional information
that it wants but can also discard it as
it as it prefers
um and so this is the standard way it's
done of course in the in the context of
architectures that use fourier or
sinusoidal like features um but there's
a lot of flexibility here
okay so now just thinking in terms of
how confidence um relate to transformers
sort of at the opposite end um it may
look like that we have a sort of
scalability versus general generality
trade-off
and so if we look at confidence
the way that they're applied
so typically we can think about using
them on grid structured data
they're they're of course
generalizations of convolutions that
work on
on data sets with more interesting
topology but typically we can think of
them as operating on grids of some in
some in some sort of space
um whereas transformers apply to generic
sets so uh transformers are more general
from this point of view
on the other hand they're um they scale
much much worse so confidence are linear
both in the uh the input points the
filter size and the number of layers of
that architecture whereas transformers
have this quadratic scaling um and
they're still linear and then in the
depth
so from this point of view um what we're
interested in doing in this in the
perceiver line of work was to scale
transformers but to keep the generality
properties so we want something that
lives in between these two extremes
uh and the way that we do this is by um
by looking at at self-attention and sort
of modifying it in a way that allows us
to scale better so to walk through what
self-attention actually does in sort of
standard transformers
we take our input array which here is
written as the number as the indices
which is the number of tokens or the
number of pixels um basically the number
of input units depending on what you're
looking at and the number of and the
channels um we have a 1d convolution so
this is big o of m
with respect to the q k and v
we then compute the attention maps using
the output of this operation this gives
us a matrix multiply which is the source
of the quadratic scaling
and then finally we compute output
features with another matrix multiply
this is
already we're already rate limited here
because um for even standard resolution
images m is quite large so it's around
50 000
for standard image net images which
again are very small so this is uh this
is something that just isn't going to
work if we want deep architectures
so what we do is we replace um at the
input to the architecture we replace the
self-attention with a cross-attention
layer and we do this using
basically a learned query and so we're
replacing only the query from the the
input here with a learned component and
so these indices and channels you can
just think of these as basically working
like um the learned initial state for an
rnn there's a variety of names that this
this opera this idea goes under in the
literature um we refer to them as sort
of as um as late as latents um but
they're sometimes called inducing
inducing points or other things
um so the basic idea is we're learning
the input to the query and keeping the
key value input the same
the downside are the the sort of upside
of this is that um
when we compute the attention map after
this now we um we basically turn this
from a square matrix to um to a
rectangular matrix
and um reduces the complexity of the
matrix multiplied to big o of mn so now
it's linear in the input size
and the second the second matrix
multiply has the exact same property so
it becomes from quadratic becomes linear
um and the the quite cool thing about
this is that okay so the cross attention
is linear in complexity but the output
is actually smaller and so this i think
is actually the more important point
here is that this allows us to map
something which is quite large into
something that has size that's
independent of the input we so we have
full control over this it's a hyper
parameter and this allows us to build
deep networks on top of this arc on top
of this latent so because this is of a
small size that we can control we can
afford to have quadratic complexity on
top of this
and so we use this idea um yep
sorry i'm still a little bit confused as
to on how you guys are able to
turn this square into a rectangle in the
second step is it because you replaced
the query with the learned something
that is significantly smaller compared
to the input size in the first step
yeah that's exactly right so if you look
at the um so the the um the underlying
matrix multiplication multiply here
which is written as the qk transpose
so the um this will basically so the
outer dimension here is has this has
shape n which is determined by the query
and so by shrinking that query we're
just changing the output of the matrix
multiply
okay thank you
yeah so i guess
sorry go ahead please okay cool um so
basically you only do that for the query
right so key and value remain like the
original um size matrices correct
that's right yeah okay um but
so basically so
i um
i don't know what i'm not understanding
basically so the problem for me is that
for the query
now in my head i'm like looking for
let's say i have like the if token now
there is no i query anymore
doesn't that pause cause a problem
like when i'm trying to use it
and like to compute scores
yeah so um so what's happening here is
um uh you're comparing you'll have a
smaller subset of query so if you think
about this in not in terms of the matrix
multiplies but in terms of comparing
each query to each key
so in normal self-attention we have one
query for each key so every point
compares to every other point right so
here what we've done is instead of
comparing every point to every other
point we have a set of sort of cluster
centers you might be able to think about
them as so it's a smaller number and we
compare each of those to each of the
input points
but we don't know which
which tokens technically belong to which
clusters right
that's right so it has to be learned
yeah exactly
um so one way to think about this um
about what's happening here is that
we're we're um we're um instead of so in
a normal self-esteem self-attention
transformer by comparing all to all to
all we're sort of saying okay i know
what the feature is at this point and i
want it to attend to similar features um
here what we're saying is we're learning
a bunch of supplementary um points that
we that that should be sort of maximally
similar to some subset of the inputs
uh so correct me if i'm wrong but this
is essentially doing some sort of heart
attention where you're saying like uh
like instead of like declaring over all
the points it's like like some points
which we think are like very similar and
only like puts out attention
uh hardened like this points you're
selecting right
yeah so they're related um the um that
would be one way to think about it the
um the the sort of the slight uh
modifier to that idea though is that um
they basically live in an abstract space
so they're not they're not assigned sort
of one to one to one of the input
queries or to one of the input points
they're sort of learned so they can be
somewhere in the middle but i think
that's a that's a good way to think
about it that's a good intuition
but
i guess one of the places where i'm a
little confused here is the
you have here indices and indices for
the two like the purple and green
matrices in the far left
but those indices are not necessarily
corresponding to inputs like in the nlp
space those would not necessarily be
tokens right these are just sort of
exact variances but the structure matrix
in this case is the result of some kind
of mapping from the input tokens to an n
by d matrix is that right
no it's actually so there it basically
acts like it's a learned set of weights
is one way to think about it so they
function exactly the same way that
learned position encodings do so it's
basically just a you know it's a learned
embedding um but it's not it's not
conditioned on anything it's just sort
of
it just it just uh is
it's what it's just a set of weights
that that makes more sense thank you
uh okay so if there if there are no more
questions i'm gonna um i'm gonna keep
going but of course feel free to
interrupt me
so the um the way that um given this
idea so we have this uh learned latent
array which again it functions sort of
like an rnn initial state or it's a set
of weights
um we basically uh randomly initialize
that and then we use this to attend on
to um the input byte array and so the
byte array here is is the flat instead
of pixels for example for imagenet
and the output of this is going to live
in the same space as so the same index
space as the latent array does
and there's residual connections in the
in the way that you would normally do in
a
in a in an attention layer as well
um so once we're in the space we can
then build an architecture by taking um
by using a standard transformer but
phrased in the latent space rather than
in the input space
and um this is going to allow us to
basically end up because we've sort of
distilled the input down to the smaller
space we can still flexibly allow all of
these points to interact so this should
be still as nearly as expressive as a as
the transformer as a normal transformer
is
and then each of the modules here now is
quadratic in the latent size rather than
the input size so this is something that
we can control um quite a lot
so in the in the original original
version of the perceiver we found it was
very helpful to um
have additional crosstones so so this is
certainly something that you can do um
and the reason the the sort of the
intuition behind this is that um if this
bottleneck is quite is quite severe we
can't maintain all of the information
from the input and so we want these
queries which are now sort of
conditioned on the past to be able to
look um back at the input point and so
this um this
this is something that we found to be
quite helpful in when tuning for the
first paper but the caveat i will say is
that we're no longer recommending this
as best practice because these cross
attentions end up being quite heavy but
this is something that you can explore
certainly if you want sort of more
conditional queries or if you want to be
able to cross attend to new inputs that
are coming in
the other thing that we found quite
helpful in the context of
data sets that have a limited amount of
data which for these architectures
includes imagenet is to allow weight
sharing in depth and so this basically
just amounts to tying the weights um for
the different cross-attention and
different self-attention layers as
they're repeated so this ends up looking
like an rnn that's enrolled in depth
um so this is um
just at a high level um this gives us an
architecture that we can apply to images
but it doesn't make any assumptions
about image structure so it's one that
you can use elsewhere um and uh we
basically um
we
we give information about the uh the
input sort of spatial structure by
having positional encodings and here we
use a 2d fourier feature position
encoding and just to show you kind of
what that looks like here to give you a
sense
so each of the input points is assigned
basically so you'll have you'll be in
some position here and we have
sinusoidal and cosine soil features in
2d so this is basically a 480
composition of the position of the 2d
input
and a couple of things that we found
were that
if we sampled the frequency that's the
maximum frequency that's used up to the
nyquist frequency of the of the signal
we um we end up doing um better than if
you use a lower version of this and this
basically is because this will allow the
um every other point to be aware of
every every distinct point in the image
whereas if you sample at a lower
frequency you can end up with aliasing
and so not all points will be um sort of
legible
we also found that sampling the spectrum
relatively densely tends to help
and the contrast here
at the time we were developing this was
with respect to nerf so nerf at least in
earlier implementations used um quite a
a small number of frequency bands we
found that the more we added the better
we did so so in general this is
something to be to be attentive to
um and then finally as opposed to
language where you typically have
addition of whatever you're embedding is
with the uh the sinusoidal or position
encoding that you use um here we find we
found that concatenating them performed
consistently better and so this may be
because the positioning the the the
content embedding is not as sparse as it
is in language we're not totally sure
but this is something that i observed
consistently
um and before i move on to results i
just want to contrast this to some sort
of other other approaches for um for
using transformers in in the image
context so the obvious um the obvious um
precedent here is visual transformers
and um i i think this is a this is a
very um this line of work is is great
especially in the image context but
there are some caveats about it that
make it less less suitable for sort of
more general um more general purpose use
uh so one is that um so vision
transformers do use an input 2d
convolution so this is often phrased in
terms of patches input patches it's a
special case of a 2d transformer so it
does restrict
the class of inputs you can use it for
um and because we're basically building
this patching or transform or
convolution into it this means that
this has an approach really isn't
sufficient to get it to work on non-grid
data there are other ways you could
adapt it but this is something that you
will have to special case for every
domain you're looking at
and then finally because we have this
sort of input where we're i'm telling
the architecture what it should look at
first in the initial grouping this does
amount to getting rid of the
non-locality assumption
it's not super clear how doing how much
doing this just once will make a
difference but this is something to be
aware of when you're thinking about this
architecture
and then finally cross-attention itself
is used quite broadly um in the vision
literature so um
just a couple to highlight a couple of
examples um deader
which is a an object detection method
from facebook basically has a
convolutional backbone that's then used
to give an output feature map this is
then passed into and transforming code
or decoder and of course whenever you
hear encoder decoder you can cross
attention because from the encoder the
decoder there's a cross attention step
and so they're using basically the cross
attention to go from some feature map
representation to something that looks
more like the object bounding boxes
there's also quite nice work
on
learning
self-supervised or unsupervised object
segmentation models um
and uh in this work they're doing
something very similar where they have a
convolutional backbone they then use um
something like um these latent uh the
latents that we introduce here
to do um to they call them slots here
but basically to assign um some of the
output pixels to um to different slots
so that they sort of have independent
complementary decoding of the slots in
the in the segmentation model here
and there's a there's a lot of other
things
um okay so first i want to just so now
i'm going to sort of walk you through
results of this of this model
um hi can i oh go ahead
yes i'll go after you go for it
okay cool uh sorry for that
can you go back a couple of slides where
you had like the you know like how
uh how like the inputs like flow into
like um i think one about yeah that one
okay um there's two questions so the
latent transformer is basically like a
self-attention is that correct
yeah so the latent transformer is a
self-a fully self-intentional
transformer
got it and um why
is see like for like the key and value
they flow direct into your cross
attention and there is like
the query also flowing into it but the
latent array is flowing into the cross
attention in parallel to the query can
you explain that
yeah so this is just um
here
yeah um it's it's meant to depict the
residual connection so the um the the
cross attention this is sort of a cross
attention depicted as a cross attention
and so the cross-attention itself has
the attention it has a residual
connection and then there's an mlp so
that's what that's meant to indicate
okay
but it it's basically the qkb is
standard
got it
thanks
hi uh i had a question
that is uh slightly related to this we
can just stay up this slide actually so
i think one thing that's interesting
about this art
for sure
consisting of attention layers whether
it's retention or in image transformers
can you hear me is that coming through
oh it's cutting off i think yeah but i
think some recent work oh okay
should i type it is that should i type
yeah that's a good idea yeah okay i'll
type it thanks sorry
all right
feel free to go ahead i'll type it
slowly and
sounds good sounds good to me yeah
actually can i chime in drew while
you're on that previous slide um yeah
so these residual connections i actually
didn't know the cross attention use them
how reliant are the sequential cross
attention layers on the residual
connections
um yeah so here um
here uh in the initial so the um
two things i will say is that um the in
the initial cross attention um it
doesn't really make a difference
um so this is something we've ablated um
when we get to the procedure i o version
of this we also did the same thing in
the decoder um cross attention and it
can make some of it different it can
make a difference there depending on
what you're doing um i think it's it's
actually essential in the content when
you're using repeated cross-attention of
this way so when you have this sort of
iterative structure and the reason for
this is that the the thing that's
actually used to condition the query is
um is basically all that that's your
your full representation of the sort of
the state of the architecture so far
and so the the skip connection is from
the um it's it's in basically the query
channel it's in the latent the latent
space and so this is basically what
allows you to end up with this sort of
dense dense and stable architecture
okay thank you
okay
so to imagenet um okay so in standard
image net processing um basically um we
compare against um a few um so this is
this is a little bit out of date at this
point but uh against a few sort of um
just sort of sanity check um baselines
here so i'm comparing against resident
50 and then at the time the best um
vision transformer model that was purely
on imagenet and we're um we're
definitely in the ballpark this isn't um
these aren't
anywhere near state of the art results
but um this is an architecture that
again is not using any 2d convolutions
and so the fact that it was able to do
this well was we found very very
surprising at the time um one of the the
quite cool things about this is that
because this architecture is not making
any assumptions the architecture itself
isn't making any assumptions about the
the um the spatial structure of the um
of the input images we can look at
permuted image net and in the first
version of this what we do is basically
um we compute the features using the 2d
position so the 2d position is sort of
fixed to a position to the pixel and
then we just shuffle them all and so
this is um basically will give you a
sense of how dependent the bass lines
are on the input image structure and so
if we look at um if we look at the
transformer perceiver by construction
they don't change so this is this is not
an empirical finding this is a property
of the models um but we find that
resonance 50 um falls by the performance
falls by about half
and vit which again only has one layer
where it's relying on the spatial
structure also has about a 15 point drop
and so this suggests that it's relying
quite a lot on that very first one
to give it some information about the
structure
we can push this a little bit by instead
of relying on 2d
fourier features learning completely
learned positional encodings and this
basically this um this is an
architecture now this is a model that
has absolutely no information about the
input structure um and so shuffling them
and learning them again is absolutely
equivalent and we find that this
architecture also can be pushed above 70
and we've gotten slightly better numbers
here um in general this seems to work
worse but um so the 2d information is is
useful but it's quite cool that you can
get what would have been
numbers comparable to
of the art about five five or six years
ago so this is quite cool
sorry i'm a little thick here uh
you're saying
the difference between the last two rows
is that the uh
second to last row has a two dimensional
position embedding and the last one has
a one-dimensional position of betting
essentially is that right
uh so it's it's learned so um you it's
um basically it's it's a it'll be um
it's a i believe a 256-dimensional
vector that's learned um but it doesn't
uh it basically does um
it it means that the model itself has no
information about the input spatial
structure
so the um the 2d positional encodings
that we're using you know end up having
about 200
it's 200 some features depending on what
you're looking at but they're always
they give you very detailed information
about the 2d structure of the input
because they're based on a fourier
decomposition of the input space
okay that makes sense thank you
hi drew i can ask you a question about
uh frequency you use to generate those
uh essential other way
yeah so like a cover slide before
yeah oh
yeah yeah this slide
so
basically i i do have taken some
lectures
in signal processing and i know if i
want to avoid
you know alienc i need to sample with at
least nyquist frequency so i'm curious
to know why to use frequencies starting
from
one to the nyquist frequency instead of
starting from my microsd frequency to
some very high frequency
i see so the um basically um
so um the maximum frequency that's used
is always nyquist
so anything about likewise is going to
be alias so you're not actually going to
be able to resolve it
um
because it's in pixel space right so um
we sample
one is basically just giving you an
oscillation that covers the entire image
um and so this is this is uh basically
just to sample the full range of
non-aliased frequencies
oh okay cool thank you
[Music]
okay
okay so um so um after uh after the
image results we wanted to try it on
other domains and in particular we were
interested in how this could be used to
to work on sort of multimodal domains so
once combining various different um
types of input features
and um
the one one challenge or one sort of
problem that you encounter in these
sorts of spaces is that the data from
different modalities end up having
different features and they always have
different semantics so if you take the
positional encoding plus the um the rgb
for video you end up with some number of
channels and then if you have audio that
corresponds the data may be paired but
it tends to have fewer features and it
only has a 1d position 1 coding so the
way that we handle this is basically by
learning modality specific position
encodings and so these are basically
embeddings that are special and learned
for each of the modalities and what this
does is basically tags ends up tagging
the features that come from audio or
video with some information that the
network can learn that allows it to
distinguish which ones which
but given these um these padded these
sort of learned padded
feature vectors we then concatenate them
all and that's how we process a
multi-modal data so basically the input
to the architecture still looks like
just one big array it's just that when
constructing this we know that some of
those features some of the rows in that
array come from video and some come from
audio but the model itself isn't given
information about that other than what
it learns
uh we also have some questions
yeah so you can go first
foreign
basically a positional embedding is um
it's a feature that says this um so so
i'm in the simplest way to think about
it is in text so text um the input is 1d
so things live in some 1d sequence and
for each point there you featurize where
it's located in that sequence so the
simplest thing to do would be if you
have negative 1 to 1 is the full range
it's just
denotes actually where it's located in
that sequence but we typically will add
um sort of uh we will we'll want to
featurize this to have more dimensions
than just a single one and so the
fourier transpo
the fourier decomposition is one way to
do this to sort of give it privileged
information about the high frequency
structure but we can also just use the
position to index onto some embedding
array which is um which is how we do it
when we're learning things so basically
it's just a set of weights that are
added to the feature for that point that
give the network information about where
it's located in the in the ground
sequence
you want to go next
sorry i had to find a mute button
um
okay so i actually have two questions
regarding the fewer features about three
features um the
i think like do you guys sample them
like uniformly or um
are they
like
um do you like to learn these
yeah so um so basically we um we sample
them linearly so basically we take the
full space and we sample them linearly
with whatever the budget is
um
there are um
so in in various settings we have
actually tried learning these so you
could actually initialize an array with
them and then learn them and that does
help sometimes actually um and you could
potentially learn you could try a more
sophisticated strategy on this too
okay cool my follow-up question is that
basically i feel like the selling point
of uh your research right is that you
don't make any structural assumptions
right you can take any type of like
format
um however for like the encoding
wouldn't the dimensionality so for
example
um like if it's text it's 1d right if
it's a
like an image it will be 2d and if it's
like a video with 3d um you have like
more um
like the positions in coding will have
like more points right wouldn't that
like inherently give away
like the nature of the um of the input
yeah so it does um so i completely agree
with this you're totally right um
the the version of this where we have
learned position encodings is the most
pure from that point of view so it's one
that gives it basically no information
about the the ground truth spatial
structure
what it does give the um the model so
when you do the learn position encoding
it will say that for example there is a
correspondence between point k on image
one and point k on image two so that's
basically the the least amount of
information you can give it while still
allowing it to sort of figure out what
the structural relationship between the
input points is
so this is the direction that we've been
trying to push in
um in general giving the architecture
access to sort of ground truth
structural information like this lives
on this point in 2d um is helpful so
um there's there's a couple things here
there's there's sort of from a practical
point of view if you want good results
you need to exploit these things or it's
helpful to exploit these things but we
do want to move in the direction where
we're relying on these things less
and so this is this is basically
something we're actively looking into
okay make sense thank you
so i think has posted her question
on on the chat uh i also see you have
your hand raised so if you if you want
you can give it a try um if not i'll
read out the question
okay i'll try just let me know if it's
choppy
but yeah so is it good right now so far
so good yeah oh good okay cool so i was
curious uh looking at the perceiver
diagram you had it's a bunch of
attention layers right like cross
attention and self-attention and
i think uh there's been this like small
trend in recent work in vision
transformers to try to sort of replace
the last few layers instead of having
attention like make them be convolutions
to address this attention scaling
problem right in a different manner and
so here like the perceiver architecture
is trying to make self-attention less
expensive
and uh there they're just trying to
replace it and they kind of just avoid
the problem
and so i'm curious um and so i've seen
papers both ways like some that try to
do things like the ones you cited and
then some they're trying to do this as
well and uh in my mind everyone always
has like the good results and stuff so
i'm curious if you think there's a
reason to do one or the other or if you
think this alternative approach is also
promising or is there a reason you know
research should go in one direction or
the other
yeah so to my mind the big trade-off is
one between so um
the the vision literature i think is um
it's just exploded in terms of these
sort of hybrids and people yeah
they'll write the exact right um place
on the pareto curve for the trade-off of
speed and and uh performance but they're
basically looking primarily on vision
specific problems so something i see
the the the computer vision community
itself typically doesn't regularize
itself away from things that don't work
on on things that aren't vision
so you end up with things that are very
very efficient very performant on vision
problems um
i think from that point of view that's
an it's an incredibly important line of
work and that that's probably the right
way of do of doing things
what we're sort of aiming for is
something um is the things that are as
as general as possible while still kind
of being performant
so
this kind of thing is critical oh sorry
to pull you off go ahead
no no please go ahead i was gonna say so
this kind of thing is like it's
important
just to summarize so you feel like it's
important to focus on attention because
that's kind of critical for nlp like you
can't just sort of put in a convolution
at the end and sort of fix the problem
but in vision maybe you can and it's
fine is that a right way of
understanding it
um that's part of it um vision and nlp
aren't the only two domains and so the
certain that we're yeah
are really basically um so the kinds of
problems um that that we're interested
in doing with this include things like
event based cameras um cell biology uh
sort of proteins all of these sorts of
things where um we may or may not have
the right convolutional inductive biases
for to even know how to build those
sorts of things
they end up being whole research
programs like the mesh based convolution
work
oh cool thank you i also had like one
more question about the architecture so
i saw that i'm sorry if you said this
and i just missed it but you had close
attention and then like deterrently to
transformer and then cross attention i'm
curious what happens if you replace the
self potential in those layers with
cross attention does it affect your
accuracy is that even feasible is that a
valid question
yeah so um the sort of thing that you
could do is you could modify this to
make it sort of hierarchical so that
there are multiple pages attention we
haven't gotten this working yet but it
doesn't mean it's not a good idea
um so there might be there might be a
right way to do this that we haven't
figured out right but it's something we
have tried a little bit
oh cool okay thank you so much i
appreciate it
yeah no problem
okay let me
um
we're running short on time so maybe
i'll skip ahead
um
okay so i
before we run uh too much time i want to
at least talk about the um the sort of
the modifications to this architecture
that we've made to make it work sort of
even more generally so one of the
problems of the um the sort of the first
um the first architecture that we looked
at here the basic perceiver is that it
works
basically for arbitrary inputs
but um it's uh it's designed to work
only on classification or regression
tasks as an output
and so basically um we wanted to see if
we could use the same um the same
cross-attention strategy for decoding
and it turns out you can it's um it's
something that works pretty well just
kind of out of the box
so the idea is that um we have um if we
have our cross attention input and
self-attention sort of to do the
processing we can introduce a set of
additional queries and these are
basically queries that give the
semantics of each of the points that
you're trying to decode
and we pass this as input to another
cross attention layer which is
configured in basically the opposite way
that the encoder cross attention is
configured so now the queries are going
to be something that's potentially large
and the keys and values are coming from
this latent and so what this allows us
to do basically is to keep all of the
nice advantages of the original
perceiver so we have an encoder that
scales linearly we have a processor
stage this sort of latent self-attention
that scales independently of the input
size and we now have a decoder that
keeps the the decoupling but gives us
linear scaling with respect to output
size
and so by doing this we can now um
basically
apply the same approach to basically
dense dense output tasks
and so to give you a sense of how this
works just sort of intuitively
um if we're if we're doing auto encoding
on this um image of puppies uh basically
we um what we do is we encode process
and then to decode we take a query that
corresponds to each of the points and
then we pass it into this decoder so we
can query one of the points we get one
pixel query another one we get another
one and all the way up
until we get all 10 000 points and
that's how we can do reconstruction with
this
and the cool thing about this is that it
opens up a bunch of new applications
um so
and we can get different kinds of
outputs just by changing how the queries
work
so if we want to do something like
multimodal auto encoding where we have
some of the outputs or videos we use the
same construction trick to get
positions
that to get queries that are have the
relevant semantics for each of the
points that we're decoding
and we can do we can do this even though
the um the basically the sizes of these
different data so the number of points
they have is quite diverse um so in the
multimodal audio encoding experiments
that we have that we have in this paper
we do this for video audio and labels at
the same time so that all of them are
just passed into the uniform network and
then decoded one by one in this way
but we can also do
mass language modeling now by by
conditioning on the position in a
sequence
we can do multi-task classification by
having basically an index that gives
which task you're querying from the
network
and we can do things like optical flow
by passing in input features as well as
the positions
and so i'm just going to
just quickly skip to a couple of the
different
i can i can share these slides with you
with you all afterwards um to look
through them um
some of some of these things are quite
cool but um
just quickly i want to talk about
language and then optical flow
so for um for language basically what we
what we wanted to do with this was to
see if we could use this to replace um
tokenization
and um why
might we care about getting rid of
tokenization so one we use tokenization
primarily because transformers scale
poorly with sequence length and
tokenizing because sequence length by
about a factor of four
um but um but there are various problems
that arise with this and so um so my why
why might we care about removing
tokenizers
so uh for one
uh tokenizers perform less well on rare
words so if you compare the sort of the
byte based decomposition um the utf-base
uh utf-8 encoding of an input of an
input sequence like this you can see
that there's basically a uniform
allocation of
of points in memory to each of the input
characters the exception or diacritics
which end up splitting into two
but if you look at the sentence piece
tokenization so it's learned that pepper
is one one token but jalapeno gets split
into into five in this case so this this
basically says it's it's um the the
amount of capacity that you allocate
depends on how rare the word is which
can lead to some optimal encodings
um they're also brittle to subtle
perturbations a famous example of this
is that um if you um enter so if you've
ever played around with gpt3 um you'll
notice that the output can be quite
sensitive to where if you add a space or
emit a space at the end and this
basically is because the space can end
up being factorized into different parts
of the tokenization there are other
problems there are other things that can
happen there too but this is one one
cause of that
um and finally um tokens don't transfer
across across languages so if you wanted
to have a model that without any tuning
could be used on many different
languages at the same time tokenizers
are a blocker for this so if we can get
rid of them it'll simplify the pipeline
it'll also make things less brittle and
then hopefully lead to more general
models
so the way that we do mass language
modeling is the same as the way that i
showed in that schematic auto encoding
experiment so we mask um some fraction
of our inputs about 15 is sort of the
standard magic number
um we then decode at each of the
positions that are masked and we tasked
the model with decoding whatever
characters were more masked at those
locations
and then once we have this model so this
is what we do for pre-training we can
then fine-tune fine-tune it by replacing
the decoder with a multi-task decoder
that takes in the tasks that we're using
on the fine on the on the downstream
evaluation um setting and training the
model to uh to reconstruct the logits on
a per task basis
um okay so to look at how this model
performs we um basically first compare
it to bird base so this is just a solid
benchmark that we understand very well
and um first by looking at um sort of
matched
two models that have matched flops we
can see that the um that perceiver i o
and
bass work on par
you see there's a different trade-off
here so to get the same number of flops
basically we make perceiver i o deeper
and this ends up giving it more
parameters but at a flaw on a per flops
basis um it ends up performing about the
same
um on the other hand if we remove the
tokenizer from bert and keep the flops
flops the same we see that the number of
parameter the number of parameters in
the depth just drastically fall down and
this is because
bert scales quite poorly with sequence
length because it uses a normal
transformer
but if we use a perceiver without the
tokenization
we can see that
we only get a slight reduction in the
number of parameters at the flops count
but the performance performs almost
exactly the same
so this means that the perceiver the
perceiver in the setting is performing
basically the same with and without the
tokenization it's learning a different
strategy it's using different parameters
but it basically can be brought to the
same performance
we can then scale this more by sort of
leaning into what happens in the
tokenizer free setting and we see that
we can get a moderate modern performance
boost as well
i think it's also in the language
setting it's also useful to look at what
the attention the attention maps that
are sort of learned and what's being
visualized here are basically for each
of the latents for some subset of the
latents we're looking at where it's
attending to in the input sequence
and some of these end up being local so
point looking at specific points in the
sentence
some of them are periodic so they look
sort of at recurring points over the
sequence
and some of them also look like they
pick out syntactic features which is
quite nice so they pick out basically uh
exclamation points or capital letters or
other punctuation that's quite useful
and decodable from very um right right
at the beginning of the end of the
sequence
um we can also basically use this um
this exact same architecture on optical
flow
an optical flow is um is basically an
important classical problem in computer
vision where given a pair of frames in a
video we want to basically track all of
the points so figure out the motion from
every point from one frame to the other
and so optical flow is usually
visualized using this um these sort of
colorized images that are shown on the
bottom and what this gives you basically
is a per pixel indication of the
velocity at every single point
and so you can see that um
so so the um the the blade the the the
character here is holding is moving to
the right whereas this uh this creature
behind her is sort of moving as moving
downwards
um
so there are a couple of problems with
um with optical flow that make it um
make it interesting to um to sort of
approach so one is it's a dense task and
it basically involves um long-range
correspondences but the standard
training protocol there's basically no
large scale realistic training data just
because it's incredibly hard to sort of
label all of the pixels in a real world
scene and figure out where they go to
so the typical way to do this is to
train on some synthetic data and then
evaluate on more realistic scenes
and um optical flow is also interesting
because it's um basically the locus of
some of the most complicated visual
architectures uh in the literature so
the previous state of the art result
here is this method called raft which
won the best paper award at dccv last
year and i'm just highlighting this to
give you a sense of how much work people
do into sort of hand engineering these
architectures
so this is a very very cleverly designed
architecture and basically it
incorporates things like global
correlation volumes that are explicitly
computed at different offsets to
basically allow the model to reason
about how things that different scales
are moving with respect to each other
it also has
local neighborhood gather operations
as well as update blocks to keep track
of what's happening within each specific
correlation block
and then finally there's some
flow specific up sampling operators that
were developed
so in contrast to this um we're
basically um we wanted to see how well
perceiver i o would do here and just to
give you a sense of sort of what we were
expecting coming into this we thought
well maybe um so perceiver io is
throwing a lot of the structure away so
we were hoping that we would get some
good results but it would probably
overfit and there's this sort of problem
of the domain transfer that's happening
here but on the other hand
self-attention seems to be a reasonable
way to match this sort of correspondence
thing
what we actually found was that um just
by doing the ver very very simple
preprocessing here so extracting
basically a patch around each pixel
and then using the the standard
perceiver i o architecture we were able
to get state-of-the-art results here and
so this is um this is basically um
was validation of this general approach
of trying to have general purpose
architectures that would transfer over
um and so basically um the with minimal
tuning we're able to get um results that
are beat
both of the um sort of compelling
benchmarks
on sent on both of the cintel
the cental evaluation methods and to get
comparable results on kitty so these are
the standard ones
and we can also sort of visualize what
what happens
when we apply this on real world data so
there's no ground truth here so you you
can't we can't really compare it but
it's still useful to sort of see um how
it moves around and we can see that um
qualitatively it's able to capture a lot
of the fine structure um and to um to
sort of uh get the get the right motion
for the for the things that are that are
very clearly moving in a specific
direction
um we can also sort of it's also i think
informative to look at what happens um
how it managed to represent how it
manages to represent a sort of small
structure is this video playing
yeah we can see it
okay cool so the thing to look at here
is the the fine water droplets that are
sort of flying through the air as that
bird flies by
and because we're decoding at every
single output point
um the architecture is able to represent
those so it's able to capture very very
fine scale segmentation that would be
difficult to capture if you had for
example a convolutional up sampler here
um okay so i'm just gonna oh so the
light light has gone off in this room
um
i'm just going to
also try uh other tasks like depth
estimation because
like it looks like it can also apply
well on that modalities
yeah so um so we haven't published
anything but um some internal results
suggest that it's um that it works just
fine
um they're basically um there don't seem
to be one of the one of the surprising
things um the things that we were a
little bit unsure about was how much
information was going to be contained in
this latent because basically you're
abstracting quite a lot and you're not
it doesn't have any 2d structure
intrinsically um but it does seem like
this um
it seems to be able to represent things
quite well and this um these these sorts
of decoding mechanisms do you seem to be
able to do that
um so i'm just going to interest in this
interest of time i'm going to i'm going
to skip ahead to the conclusion
i had one question with respect to the
metrics that you've shared for the
optical flow the number yeah so like the
in the table it was like central final
clean and kitty were these different
data sets or different metrics like same
metric for different data sets or like
these are three different metrics
yeah so these are three different data
sets so um sintel clean and centel final
are basically two um they're two ways of
doing the final rendering for cintel um
in in all cases these are these methods
are trained just on the autoflow data
set so they're they're trained on this
sort of general purpose um kind of uh
wacky synthetic
motion data set and then we're
evaluation we're evaluating on these
different domains without fine-tuning
okay
yeah the flow has quite the data sets
are quite small so it's it's generally
even problematic to fine-tune
uh thank you
okay so just to summarize all right what
was the ground truth to find the uh
endpoint error
uh yeah so the um the way this works is
um sintel um
is a computer it's it's basically a
relatively high quality uh cgi movie um
that was basically open source and so
they actually have the ground truth so
if you if you know the ground truth 3d
um state you can compute the the the
pixel um correspondence from from the
frame so that's what's used on cintel
and then kitty they basically have um
they have a like a
lidar sensor that's used to figure out
the depth of all points and then they
then they they compute the
correspondences so the ground truth is
actually the ground truth optical flow
um but in general it's hard to get dense
optical flow um it's very expensive to
collect it great thanks
okay so the um so basically um just to
summarize so the um perceivers are
attention-based architectures that scale
linearly and work as drop-in
replacements on for transformers on a
variety of settings they also seem to be
able to um
to achieve results that are um
comparable at least in performance with
um with models that rely on 2d
convolutions but of course there is a
trade-off here and so it's good to be
very aware of this of generality versus
versus speed in specific domains and so
as was pointed out in um in settings
where you can use 2d convolutions it's
certainly good to have them in the in
the loop
it's basically a unified architecture
that allows joint modeling of
different of different modalities of
different sizes
um and
basically
overall it seems to be a quite flexible
architecture that's able to produce a
state of the art or near
state-of-the-art results on a variety of
different domains um and um there's in
the two papers we look at a number of
other domains that i didn't talk about
including 3d point cloud modeling um
replacing the transformer that's used in
the in the starcraft um
in the sort of starcraft behavioral
cloning agent and a couple of others um
so this does we we have a lot of
evidence that this this general approach
seems to work broadly and you know
there's there's a lot of things we still
haven't tried so we're very interested
in pushing this um and you know always
always open for suggestions and um and
so forth um so we're relying on a large
um a large body of uh related work
because we're sort of drawing from a lot
of different areas here so here's some
highlights um and then i just wanted to
thank my uh my my co-authors um on this
work
and of course i'm happy to happy to talk
more
thanks drew
yeah thanks a lot thanks
uh so one question i had is like uh
so what do you think is like the future
of like uh like perceiver like models
like uh do you think like these are
going to
like being used more in like the sort of
like the transform transformer community
to replace like con and channel duster
yeah so the um i think um
broadly speaking i i think it's um
i think of perceivers now as sort of
because um we can we know how to adapt
them pretty well to um to sort of
domains where we don't have a great idea
of the right way to structure an
architecture an inductive bias so i
think that's um that's one of the really
strong cases for it so settings in which
you don't really know what the right way
to structure a problem is um i also
think um these uh these these kinds of
approaches can be used in conjunction
with confnets for sort of um things that
are as domain agnostic as needed
um but i think so multi-modal and um and
new domains is really the um that's the
real that's where this these are obvious
choices
also like what do you think are the
current bottlenecks with this and if you
don't mind like uh if you can disclose
like what is what are you working on
towards next with this stuff
uh so i can't i can't talk about too
many deals about that but um
but um the
a couple of domains
so one we don't really have a great
handle on how to use them on sort of
small small scale data so data where um
where
you don't have um you don't have the
data to sort of recover the inductive
bias so this is this is i think a really
important area um the other thing that
we um that we haven't sort of talked
about here but you you could probably
imagine that we'd be thinking about
would be how to train on multiple
modalities or sort of multiple things at
the same time so um so right now all of
these architectures are sort of trained
in in isolation um but but um there are
a lot of opportunities for sort of
figuring out how to pose problems
together and use a single architecture
on all of them
got it also sure if you tried but can
you also use this for like tabular data
stuff
yeah
um so so um effectively the architecture
treats um any input data as tabular data
so i think that's that's exactly the
right way to think about it
sounds good yeah thanks to the top i
will open my general questions for the
students
so i'll start the recording